EUGENE MUTAI: And
today, I'm going
to talk about REST matters,
and you need more of it.
So most of us-- or
companies, startups,
developers-- we've
been developing
using RESTful architectures,
RESTful APIs, REST itself.
But we've never really
stopped and asked ourselves
why in the first place.
Some of us have,
and then moved on
to develop softwares using SOAP.
But few of us, very few of
us, have stopped and asked
themselves, why do
we use this REST,
and what is this REST
in the first place?
What are the advantages
of REST over the SOAP
or [INAUDIBLE], which
were introduced way
before REST itself, and which
are more secure in some form.
So I'm going to
dive in straight.
So I'm basically
trying to explain
what is REST,
advantages of REST,
and trying to demystify it
so that we can all understand
it and be on the same page.
Yes, so this is a Google
Developers expert event.
We'll skip that.
Let's dive in.
So the meaning of REST, we
all know that, I hope so.
But it's basically
Representational State
Transfer.
It was defined by Thomas
Fielding when he was making
his doctorate dissertation.
One thing I need to
make clear right now,
or a few things I need to
make clear right now is one,
REST is not an API.
It is used in the
API's architecture.
It is not an API.
Two, REST is not a protocol.
SOAP is a protocol.
Three, REST is not a standard.
It is not a must to use it.
You can level up
web applications
however you want it, but it
is not a specific standard.
Four, is not a drop-in
replacement for SOAP.
You cannot just say, today, I
want to replace a SOAP API with
REST immediately.
So now that we are on the same
page with those three thoughts,
let's move on.
So if I describe REST
with [? instruction ?]
or with the fewest
words possible,
REST is a non-XML-based,
web-based RPC or RMI.
RPC basically means
Remote Procedure Call,
or Remote Method
Invocation if you're
using object-oriented
programming or frameworks.
REST works entirely
on HTTP standard.
It heavily depends
on HTTP because it
defines all its standards,
or all its architecture
using HTTP.
Robert Fielding, when he came
up with the REST architecture,
at the same time,
HTTP was on Version 1,
and he was also working
at HTTP Version 1.1.
HTTP Version 1.1 introduced
four other methods
in HTTP, which are
basically PUT, POST, UPDATE.
And later on, a few more
others were introduced.
We'll go through that together.
It heavily relies on JSON.
We all know that.
When you hear about REST,
the next thing we think about
is JavaScript and JSON, or AJAX.
It heavily relies on JSON,
but it is not a fact,
or it is not a must that
you use JSON with it.
You can use XML,
you can use HAL,
or you can use YAML-- Yet
Another Markup Language--
to send data to and fro.
REST is data-driven.
The SOAP API, which
came out in 1998,
is when the internet
was growing up.
And with remote
procedure call, we
thought that the methods
that-- or the programming
that we do in our laptop,
basically, when you are going
to put it into
the internet, it's
just taking the same functions,
putting them in a server,
and letting people
call those servers.
But now we've moved to a world
where data is the new gold.
And if data is the new
gold, you need a way
of at least protecting it.
And REST allows us to do
that in some small ways.
And because of that, it
is mostly data-driven.
Because people asking
for data or asking
to read data, and
basically, you're
not asking to do procedures
or calls, or specific actions.
So I think, when I went
through my research about REST,
is that the biggest advantage
REST has over SOAP--
and you'll ask me, why am
I comparing it with SOAP?
SOAP was the architecture--
it's actually a protocol.
SOAP was the protocol
which was being used
before REST was introduced.
And when REST was introduced,
it changed almost everything.
And some people still use
SOAP, which is not a bad thing.
It's a very good thing
to use SOAP depending
on your system's architecture.
But because most people have
moved to REST, because REST is
easy to set up and SOAP is not.
But SOAP sometimes
offers more security,
offers more stability.
But the biggest advantages of
REST over SOAP is flexibility.
Because REST, you can change
your system's architecture
permanent basis, [INAUDIBLE]
basis, or even every day
without affecting your clients'
consumption of the same data.
So let's-- for example, if my
client was [? concerning ?]
about car models and I have not
added the colors of the cars.
If I add colors of the
cars in a SOAP API,
the clients who are
consuming my API
need to restructure their API.
They need to change stuff.
I need to tell them, and they
need to change their stuff.
In REST, they don't have to.
They continue
consuming the same API.
SOAP has something called
WSDL-- Web Services Definition
Language-- where
basically, you're
creating a contract between you
and your client that's, hey,
these are contracts, I've
opened the connections for you,
you can now start consuming.
But if I change something,
the WSDL needs to change.
And if it changed, it means
our contract has changed,
and we need to create a
new contract with them.
So the biggest advantage
of REST, according to me--
it is very flexible.
You can make APIs that
stand the test of time.
SOAP is clunky but still works.
SOAP makes you put
everything in that file
that you're sending,
or let's say,
the data resource
that you're sending.
You put your request details,
your response details,
your status's details,
and your links,
and your data inside
the SOAP itself.
In REST, you don't.
Most of the things have
been defined for you.
And so REST, the only
thing you have to do
is send the data itself.
REST uses HTTP, as I said.
And the biggest advantages of
HTTP is that, since HTTP 1.1,
we have so many verbs
to use with REST.
And so REST is defined
using these verbs.
There are more verbs, such as
HEAD, PATCH, OPTIONS, LINKS,
and UNLINK.
So, an example of
how we use REST.
If I was creating a place
where I can sell music, one,
if I wanted you to see all
the albums that I have,
I can say /music/album.
You'll see all the albums.
Basically, [INAUDIBLE]
make this a GET request.
Music, albums-- maybe
the idea of the album,
for a specific album,
which you wanted to see.
Upload an album.
So the songs and the epic music
that you're supposed to upload.
This could have
been a POST request.
So the other good
thing about REST
is that the status codes
have been defined for us.
In SOAP, we have to
define them by ourselves.
And I don't know if it's
good or bad, is that we can
define however we want them.
So we know that the status 200
in HTTP means everything's OK.
In SOAP, we can say
status code 300 is OK.
Yet in HTTP, 300
means redirection.
And in SOAP, you
can use 300 if you
want to because
you're the one who's
defined your status codes.
In HTTP, they've already
been defined for you,
so you're using the ones
which are existing-- 404
for page not found, 401 for
unauthorized, and so forth.
REST is cacheable.
But it is only cacheable if
you use an idempotent request.
What idempotent request?
This is a request which uses the
HTTP verb HEAD, HTTP verb GET,
and HTTP verb OPTIONS.
All other requests
are not idempotent.
Idempotent basically
means that you
can make the request as
many times as possible,
and each and every
request does not
rely on the previous
request that you made.
So a GET request basically-- and
an OPTIONS and a HEAD request--
is cacheable, meaning that if
you made your first request
to the servers, and
for example, maybe you
need to make this request
1,000 times a day,
it means that I don't have
to process this request 1,000
times.
It means that it can be cached,
and that the next time you
make this request,
you basically fetch it
from where it's been cached,
and it will be faster that way.
Because maybe a request,
when I process it,
it takes me three seconds.
But when it's cached, you'll
get it immediately back.
So that goes down to even 10--
or 20, even-- microseconds.
Oh, so one thing I need to make
clear, SOAP uses HTTP POST.
A POST is not idempotent, so
meaning the request cannot be
cached.
So if you're going to
make a request using SOAP,
you have to make the
request every time,
and it will take the same
length for every request.
I don't know if this is a
major advantage over SOAP,
but personally, I
don't believe that.
I believe that SOAP
is a a little bit more
secure with the
introductions of WP-Security
and a few other
protocols that it uses.
REST can be secured though.
It can be secured using HTTPS,
basically sending your request
over a secure protocol.
And you can use
system architectures
such as OAuth2 and
JavaScript Web Tokens-- JWT.
So you can actually secure your
REST APIs and everything else
using HTTPS, OAuth, or even JWT.
SOAP comes with one
in-built like WP-Security.
And according to what
I read, according
to what I researched
about, WP-Security
seems much more
secure than REST.
But it doesn't mean that
REST is any less secure.
Almost at my last point
is-- REST is stateless.
Basically, stateless means
that-- let me give you
an example is that, when the
internet was starting out
and when we were moving
our systems to the web,
the introduction of remote
procedure calls-- basically,
you are taking your application
code and putting it in a server
and saying that if you want
a certain thing to be done,
you have to ping this
specific function.
In REST, it's different.
We use URIs-- which are very
readable as I've shown you
before-- like /album, /music.
And that way basically helps
us hide a lot of information
from the user or the
client who's consuming it.
The client does not need to
know which kind of server
we are running.
We can be running on Windows,
we can be running on Linux,
we can be running on Mac OS.
The client also does
not need to know
which programming
language we are
programming our systems with.
So we can be sending
him data, or he or she
can be consuming data,
but he or she does not
need to know that the
data is being provided
by Python, by Ruby, or by--
And us on the other
side with the servers
would not need to know
who the client is.
If the client is
using a mobile phone,
if the client is using a laptop,
if the client is actually
making request [INAUDIBLE]
by the introductions of IoT,
if the client is making request
to buy [INAUDIBLE] watch,
if the client is
making a request
to buy speakers, buy chairs,
whatever IoT going into.
As I mentioned before, all
requests are independent.
Every request you make does not
depend on the previous request
that you made.
Some requests are independent,
meaning that requests
can be made more than one time.
And also it's means that-- I
think I've lost that point.
But I said like, yeah, so
[INAUDIBLE] basically means
that you can make the
request several times
and in each request
is independent.
And because each request
is independent also,
we do not need to know the
servers and the [INAUDIBLE].
I basically lost the point
somewhere in my head,
but if I find it, I'll
go through it again.
So another big
advantage of REST is
because when almost
everything has
been done for us, as
developers, we get to be lazy.
We get to be very lazy.
Because most of the things
have been done for us.
So basically we're
setting up our systems
very fast with little effort,
and using the current standards
that [INAUDIBLE] have, or
the systems' architecture
have already been set for us.
And the other thing is that with
this edge, the edge of tools,
we have a tool for
almost everything
on every form of development
you can develop with.
So for example, if you're
going to test our REST APIs,
there's a very famous
tool known as Postman
which has risen over the years.
And I am sure that every
developer who uses REST
has come by this
Postman software tool.
So as I said, we get to be
lazy because these no existing
learning curve.
We basically dive in.
And in this age where time is
really important, when people
need to create things at a very
fast pace, REST supports that.
REST encourages it.
So my last point-- and
my laptop has slept.
And my last point.
Because everything has
been defined for us,
and you're using architectures,
software pieces that
are really, really
for us, we get
to ship and test on projects
every day, every second.
And that's the
final [INAUDIBLE].
Like we create a system right
now, we test it, [INAUDIBLE]
our office, we go back, fix it,
and continue life, and make it
better every day, every
second, every hour.
I don't think it
has been abandoned.
I see still major
advantages of SOAP.
SOAP, one major
difference between-- there
are a lot of major differences
between SOAP and REST,
but SOAP is action-oriented.
REST is data-oriented.
Like if basically you want
to fetch data, REST is OK.
Basically you want to carry
some form of transactions,
or some form of requests,
specifically requests,
SOAP is OK.
Then the other
thing is SOAP lets
you-- like because
it's really strict,
it lets you control how
you're [? sending ?] your data
to your client.
So if you look at Safaricom,
Safaricom uses SOAP.
And when they released the G2
API, people complained a lot.
And when they complained, this
is where I also complained.
Because I'm this kid in the
21st century who has come out.
And the new thing on the block
has risen, and all of a sudden
it's really easy to use.
And because I get to be
lazy, I get excited about it.
But when it gets to SOAP,
it's pretty complicated.
Because you need a VPN, you need
a server that connects directly
to Safaricom because there's
a contract you're locking
on [INAUDIBLE] Safaricom.
Safaricom needs you to be secure
when you're locking onto them.
And you [INAUDIBLE] them.
But if you look at what
they actually [INAUDIBLE],
they're serving M-Pesa.
M-Pesa has like over a million
users-- maybe 14 million
according to [INAUDIBLE].
Because almost all
of us uses M-Pesa.
M-Pesa is a finance system.
It deals with money.
So if you think
about it, it does not
make sense them using REST.
It makes sense
them having control
of the whole architecture,
the whole system,
and making it secure.
And saying if you're
going to connect with us,
you have to be secure, you have
to follow these specific SOAP
protocols.
Because SOAP is a protocol.
It's very strict, it's
a protocol itself.
So if you look at it, I
think the continuation
of development of SOAP,
I think it's still there.
And I remember a
few months ago, when
I wanted to play around
with the M-Pesa API,
I had to like get like a
lot of knowledge around XML
and how to act with SOAP.
And because of that,
there are things
like defining a SOAP request,
how you're supposed to make it.
Because I didn't
know it too well,
and because I live
in the age of tools,
I went online to
look for a tool.
What did I find?
I found a tool.
It's called SoapUI.
It's on Version 5.
Version 5 basically
means it's in development
and it's being developed.
So I don't think it has stopped.
SOAP is still an
alternative to REST.
Depending on how you want
to structure a system.
I feel the financial
systems are OK using SOAP
because they get more
control over their systems
compared to REST.
It actually doesn't
affect REST at all.
And I'd say they
might-- Roy Fielding,
he might make you look into
the REST architecture himself,
or somebody else,
and maybe improve
upon the current set of REST.
REST is not like
really hard to learn.
You can take a
few hours to learn
REST, that you need to make
specific [INAUDIBLE] requests
using these specific URIs.
You need to secure
[INAUDIBLE] HTTPS,
you need to know [INAUDIBLE].
So if you look at it-- and
here's the funny thing.
People think REST has been
in continuous development.
But no.
It was actually a
dissertation by Roy Fielding.
And it was released at the same
time HTTP 1.1 was released.
And that is 1998.
So ever since 1998, REST hasn't
really modified itself a lot.
So I believe REST will
maintain its current state,
the ways it is.
Or maybe be improved upon.
Because one disadvantage of REST
is that if you wanted to make
a specific execution, like
a specific call to action,
you couldn't.
This basically is you
want a specific function
to run in the servers.
You couldn't make that happen.
In SOAP, you can
make that happen.
Because you actual
calling an action.
And you're not
fetching data or trying
to change the data [INAUDIBLE].
So maybe that's one
of the improvements
I'd say REST has to make.
But if you look at it, REST,
the way it was structured,
it was structured for almost
like the 21st century.
He knew data will be there.
The thing right now
we'll be dealing with.
Because we fetch
data from Google,
we fetch data from Facebook.
We don't really want to do
any form of deep actions.
We just really need to
communicate with the servers.
When REST was released, when
Roy released the REST system's
architecture, I don't think he
had any specific programming
language in mind.
Of course there were
specific languages
that adopted REST
architecture really fast.
For example, the release
of Ruby on Rails,
which is one of the fast
[? objective ?] [INAUDIBLE]
frameworks to support REST.
But at the same-- because
JavaScript Object Notation
is used a lot,
JavaScripts [INAUDIBLE]
really, really well.
But at the same time, if
you look over the years,
people have been improving every
program language in the age.
Like Python is
moving to Python 3.0.
[INAUDIBLE] just came out.
So I wouldn't say that
it has been improved.
Ruby has been improved, it's
in version 2.2 right now.
But any programming
language has been improved.
And with improvements, they
look at the current state
of development, the current
state of things people
want to use, and
then they fuse them
into the languages themselves.
Last year, we got the
release of [? ES ?]
15 because we wanted classes
and stuff like that, because
of JavaScript.
We were saying hey, JavaScript
doesn't have classes,
we want them, and
they added them.
But if you look at REST itself,
it's a system architecture.
It's not tied to any
programming language.
So basically, we'd want like
all programming languages
to support it.
And this is the case right now.
But the problem is
that us developers,
we listen to the wind too
much and not the person
who is speaking in
between the wind.
So if you hear around from
people, people will tell you,
hey, JS is the best one
to use, we [INAUDIBLE].
Because JavaScript
Object Notation of course
came from JavaScript.
But it doesn't mean this as a
languages did not implement it.
If you go to Python, you see
that they [INAUDIBLE] JSON
file when Python reads it.
It maps everything to
the Python objects.
So for example, a string, of
course, will map to a string.
An object will map
to a dictionary,
and so forth and so forth.
So I don't think these are
specific languages is better
in dealing with REST or JSON.
But I believe that
libraries help
us to deal with things easier.
And because like
JavaScript especially
doesn't require library, it
just snaps its fingers and deals
with JSON easily, is the
fastest one, people will adopt.
Because they say, hey, this
one is easier to work with,
JSON easier.
But if you look at
programming languages
that have really,
really good libraries
on JSON, which [INAUDIBLE],
dealing with JSON seamlessly.
In that respect, I recently
began Python programming.
So I was making a RESTful API.
And I wanted to consume, of
course, JSON data being there.
Most people use JSON
to consume REST data,
to consume RESTful APIs.
If you look at it that
way, when I tried,
it has only two
lines of codes for me
to convert my data into JSON.
That was pretty easy in Python.
And in other languages like
[INAUDIBLE], it's also easy.
With PHP, it's also easy because
I've worked with all of those.
And it's just people are
really fast in thinking.
And it's good to go out there
and look at what there is.
Because if you don't
have something built in,
it's probability in the library.
Someone has made it for you.
Which is OK.
So there's no specific language
that deals with SOAP easy-- I
mean with REST easily.
All of them, I'd say, deal with
REST APIs and JSON equally.
But when it comes to
using XML, HAL-- HAL
is more JSON because of--
[INAUDIBLE] uses JSON-HAL.
XML, I'd say Java.
Because Java was the
[? fast one ?], and SOAP
was introduced way before REST.
So I'd say XML, I usually
feel like Java deals with XML
very easily.
When it comes to YAM,
I haven't met anybody.
I personally haven't
[INAUDIBLE] using [? IAM ?]
to transmit data and fro.
I use it in project definitions,
configuration files.
I don't use it to
transmit to and fro.
That I don't have much
knowledge on [? IAM ?] at all.
I don't know how
phrase it, but this
is more of a people's
opinion than more
of the REST architecture itself.
And when it comes to dealing
with people, it's a bit tricky.
You need a whole cohort.
And I know you know all the
kinds of tricks somebody
has to be use.
But sometimes some
don't work, some work.
I'd say that I've grown to
understand that you'll never
grow unless you accept change.
And accepting change
sometimes means
moving to watch your--
you are really used to do.
And that, explaining it to a
developer is pretty tricky.
I remember I used
to do some things,
and that people used to tell
me do this, do this, do this.
And until the day experimented
myself, by myself,
is that when I really said
oh, this is really awesome.
Like I should be
doing things this way.
It's much more provisional.
It makes much more sense.
I think sometimes-- OK.
I don't know if this
is-- I'm a developer.
I'm not an entrepreneur,
I'm not a business person.
But developers learn
best from failing.
We learn best from
doing the wrong thing,
then trying to look at
a way we were suggested,
and saying like, you know what,
[INAUDIBLE] suggested this
to me.
And what I've been
trying has failed.
And [INAUDIBLE]
suggested this to me.
And let me try it, and
let's see if it works.
And eventually, of
course, it works.
Because it was a
better suggestion,
it was an improvement,
everything else.
The other thing
is that-- I'm not
sure about this-- but is
that we succumb to authority.
We succumb to authority
when authority is given
in a much more stricter way.
So for example is
like [? Mandela. ?]
We learn a lot of things.
That is a big one to learn.
So for example,
continuous integration.
You need to know a bit
of almost everything.
I didn't want to go
and build the servers.
I know that somebody else is
supposed to build the servers.
But you're told like hey,
yo, the servers are down.
Deal with it.
I'll be back.
And like, uh, I can't.
And the best answer,
which usually
silences any form of any kind
of developer is that you can.
You can.
If you've done this and you've
done all these other things,
is you can.
And I'm not hearing
anything else from you
that it's impossible.
If somebody else has done
it, why don't you do it.
And when you're left
in that position,
is that you either
do it, or you get
fired because you didn't do it.
And you don't want
to lose your job
or you don't want
to lose the money.
Lose the money that you are--
you wanted to work with.
So as you see my explanation
is on a people's base,
it's not like on an
architecture base.
It's very hard
for people to move
to a new-- like for example,
my phone runs on Android 4.2.
The latest Android is 6.
This year, I'm sure
they'll release 7.
And believe me, I'm not
moving until my phone dies.
And if you look at
that state, it's
more of a person's
opinion than the-- like,
I know 7 is awesome.
I know 7 has been improved
and everything else.
But because mine still
works, and maybe some day it
will be killed,
that's when I'll move.
So REST was in the
same situation.
I think the biggest
lesson I've learned
is that technology does not
surpass human interventions.
It does not.
We say like technology will take
over everything but it's us.
Humans are pushing it.
We learned to make this.
We learned to push
it to the next level.
So much as we make
our technology,
adaptation will always
be-- like, for example,
Angular 2 has been released.
Believe me, I went to the pages
of Angular 2 over 100 times.
I was looking at it this way and
I was like I'm not going there.
I'll stay with 1.5.
It's OK.
I'll keep them.
But as long as these
are days-- like maybe
if my senior developer or my
senior trainer [INAUDIBLE]
came and said, hey,
this project is supposed
to be done with
Angular 2, the client
does not want anything else,
it just wants Angular 2.
Do I have an option?
I don't.
So I just have to adopt it.
In other cases, some people
actually are just cognitive.
They [INAUDIBLE] cognitive, and
they just adopt things easily.
So when 2 comes out, they
dive into it, look into it.
So it's a tricky aspect.
But you, you sit in a very
good position at [INAUDIBLE].
And I think you know
this more than me.
I'm learning them.
You know them more than me.
Personally, I haven't.
I haven't faced such challenges.
And I'm grateful.
I'm thankful.
I'm thankful
because [INAUDIBLE].
And believe me,
I feel I'd handle
them more stupidly than
actually right now.
Being our developer, a developer
in this place, it's a journey.
And I remember there's a
time I used to say hey,
I'm the HTML5 king and PHP king.
Then after a while,
[INAUDIBLE] PHP
didn't make sense at all to me.
And I'm like, I'm speaking
really bad about PHP.
Like you can find me making fun
of PHP every time, every day.
And at some point I was
saying I'm PHP king.
And then eventually when I
learned a couple of languages--
like right now I've learned
at least four programming
languages, Go, Python,
JavaScript, and PHP,
over time-- I don't
feel so boastful.
So I think it's a big challenge
when you start off development.
Because programming is exciting.
It's exciting when
you start it out.
And then they start learning new
things, you get very excited.
And at some point
you think you have,
you know all the
knowledge in the world
about a specific programming
language or a specific system.
If you ask me about REST a year
ago, I couldn't describe it.
I could have just
told you you make
requests via [? gat, ?]
you get back JSON.
I didn't know it's a
system architecture.
But I knew how to use it.
And we say ignorance is bliss,
but only bliss to some point.
At that point, it
was bliss for me
because I didn't see
the bigger picture.
Most of us think
that we'll remain
developers for the [INAUDIBLE].
And I remember having
this argument actually
with the same day who's
asked me this question,
is that-- I used to.
I stopped.
I used to think I'd
remain a developer
for the rest of my life.
So like in 40 years
there doing some coding
and stuff like that.
You realize when you get
good at these things,
people start pushing
you towards management.
And when you move
towards management,
you stop actually coding.
But you understand everything
that has been done.
And then the new
generation, the new guys
who have come in who are
now where you are before.
In that sense.
Or the old guys who were
born in a previous age where
these things are not there.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
EUGENE MUTAI:
Where SOAP matters.
So I think because
he's brought it up,
if I was going to
explain something
to a really old guy
who is used to SOAP,
I'd make a comparison
the same way I did.
I'd look at what you're
trying to achieve.
Are we trying to make people
carry specific actions
to our servers?
Or are we trying to collect
data, create data, and send it
as resources to the users?
And if you look at that point
and you argue with that point,
and you tell the guy, I know
SOAP is good, but look at REST.
We are doing a
data-oriented system.
We are trying to
give people data.
People are trying
to read our data.
So it's more data driven
than actually action driven.
They're not trying
to do transactions,
they're not trying to do
like specific actions.
And we don't really need
to secure these actions
because we're using--
like for example, I
didn't know back
then, I didn't know
[? gat ?] is actually safe.
It's safe and important.
I didn't know that.
I didn't know [? Post ?]
is not important.
I had to first actually
research about the word itself--
go to the dictionary,
find out the meaning
of [INAUDIBLE] in
the first place
before you move on to that.
So if you look at
that stage, if you're
moving towards-- in
most cases, you're
moving towards product manager,
product management or project
management, and you need to
know these architectures.
You need to really go research,
learn them, understand them.
As a developer, you don't
really need to know them.
Because you're
developing systems.
You just need to make the
systems work in a specific way
that you've been told.
And as a product manager,
you are in most cases,
such people face that situation.
Because you have people
higher than you who are asking
you questions.
Why are you doing
this the same way
you're doing-- so you really
need to know what you're doing.
You really need to
know what is SOAP.
What are the advantages of SOAP?
Why was it made in
the first place?
So actually even
before SOAP, there
was a system known as CORBA,
Common Object Request Broker
Architecture.
It was released in 1991.
That was the version before it.
So somebody could have faced
the same situation back then.
Why is SOAP better than CORBA?
So if you look at that,
it's going to like really
do deep research.
Then look at the
system you're trying
to build in the first place.
does it fit the SOAP basis,
or does it fit the REST basis?
Is it data-driven?
Is it action-driven?
Do you need a protocol because
you need to really secure?
Or do you need just
like a way of people
communicating with it?